[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAM O'KEEFE: Welcome.
Thank you for joining us in the
Make Google Cloud work for you
session.
In this session,
we're going to hear
from four very distinct,
very unique, and interesting
startups all
leveraging Google Cloud
Platform to build better
products and services
for their companies.
My name is Sam O'Keefe.
I work with the startup
team here at Google Cloud.
And if you are part of that
team and in the audience,
if you can just raise your
hand for me for a second.
So we've got a bunch of
people up at the front.
Take a look at these
people, because if any
of what you hear today
or have heard all week
resonates, and you want to get
your startup on Google Cloud,
or you want to talk to someone
about if it's the right fit,
how do you do that,
these are the people that
can help you out with that.
So we're going to
take some questions
from the startups following
all presentations,
so keep anything you hear
any question locked away.
We will have time for
questions at the end.
And without further
ado, I'd like
to bring up our first company.
So we have Indraneel
from LiftIgniter.
This is a bit of a
homecoming for Indraneel.
He was a research scientist
here at Google on the Sibyl team
and is now taking
everything he learned here
and creating an
awesome new company.
So please join me in
welcoming Indraneel.
[APPLAUSE]
INDRANEEL MUKHERJEE: Thanks
a lot for the introduction.
Thanks everyone for coming here.
So we are LiftIgniter,
and we use
machine learning to personalize
all your digital experiences.
So our core thesis
is everyone is
unique at every moment in time.
And the ideal digital
experience should
flow like a fluid conversation.
The website should constantly
update its contents
based on every action you take.
And here is an example of
a site that does just that.
Every time you watch a YouTube
video, a very sophisticated AI
picks 20 videos for
you to watch next
from a pool of three
billion plus videos.
And it tracks everything you
do, every click, every search.
And it's constantly updating
its contents with one sole goal,
make spend more
minutes on YouTube.
Now, I know all
this because I was
part of the five-member
team at that time
called Sibyl, which built out
the YouTube recommendations.
And when we launched
five years ago,
we added a huge improvement on
the core watch time metrics,
on top of what existed at
that time, which is already
a very sophisticated system.
And the reason we
could do this is
because we took some
very cutting edge
machine learning techniques
and implemented them
at Google scale.
And that drew all those
improvements and a huge chunk
of incremental revenue.
And it was powerful enough that
we could roll it out onto all
other major Google properties
like AdMob, Gmail, Google+,
Play Store, Product
Listing Ads, you name it.
So what we're doing
at LiftIgniter
is taking that extremely
flexible and powerful
technology, and making
it available to the rest
of the world.
And we are doing it on
Google Cloud platforms.
Thank you, Google,
for everything.
So we are super excited
because the opportunity
is incredibly large.
Almost everything you do
online, whether you're
browsing content, buying
something for your friend,
looking for the optimal
cab ride, everything
can be optimized using machine
learning personalization.
And we hope LiftIgniter is
a service that does that.
So but to make
this a reality, you
need some serious
computing power,
which is why Google
was a pioneer right?
It has the best infrastructure
and data centers.
So when I left Google, I
needed a platform like that.
And unfortunately, like about
three years ago-- three,
four years ago--
Google Cloud was
not mature enough
to support all our needs.
I had to go to some
other cloud providers.
But I'm very happy
to say that GCP
is at a point where
a small team like us
were compelled to
make the switch over.
And there are a
variety of reasons.
One of them, for instance,
there are some cool new services
which are just not available,
like containerization
as a service which is
very critical for managing
our idea of microservices.
Pricing is kind
of cool because we
have a lot of heavy
workloads, and we
don't have to do
upfront commitments
to get competitive rates.
But closest to my
heart is an opportunity
for a small business, small
or medium sized business,
to build a brand.
A better platform for exposure
to consumers for instance,
speaking at this event or other
joint marketing activities,
which the other cloud
providers don't really
help you with that much.
So if you're a small or
medium business or even
a big business trying to
build a particular brand,
I strongly urge you to seriously
consider switching to GCP.
It's going to be worth it.
So here's an example
of how we are using it.
So we're just migrating
in, so we're not fully
using every service
possible, but we are already
touching a bunch.
So Google pops up for consuming
this fire hose of events.
We are actually consuming
four billion pages per month
already.
It's a five-member
engineering team.
And we've built this
amazing scalable technology,
because it's possible
now with Google
Cloud and other providers.
So GCP pops up for
consuming the data fire
hose, Bigtable for storing
a lot of our inventory,
BigQuery for doing a
lot of the analytics,
and a lot of computer
clusters for doing
some very serious computation.
So 4 billion pages per month.
300 million items scanned daily.
And we can easily scale this 10x
to 100x with very little effort
because all the
features available.
So who are some of
the customers who are
creating all this data for us?
So you're going to
see a bunch of logos.
The main takeaway is these
are some of the biggest brands
across a variety of verticals.
Like video, music, content,
e-commerce, B2B, you name it.
We average 80% improvement
using our personalization
across all these verticals.
It just gives you
a sense of what
the power and flexibility is.
So let's dive into a
couple of use cases.
Everyone's heard of Vevo.
It's the largest
music video company.
And they use us to power
music recommendations
across their website, as
well as all other apps,
so all kinds of devices--
Android, iPhone,
television, et cetera.
And they chose us after doing
a five day head-to-head A/B
test along with four other
personalization providers.
We're happy to say
we not only won,
we beat second spot by 40%.
And the main metric of
interest was a certain kind
of engagement that they
were interested in.
And you can see it was a
sustained lift every single day
over a long period of time.
And while we crush the
performance numbers,
we are not just a black
box recommendation service.
We offer a lot of control
to fine tune our models.
So as an example, the Vevo team
wanted a special experience
where similar sounding
songs should be recommended.
So their data science
team had come up
with these cool spectral
features extracted
from the songs themselves.
And all they had to do was
upload it to our servers.
They automatically got
incorporated into our modeling.
They can manually
tune the [? weight, ?]
so that more emphasis
would be placed
on these acoustic
similarity metrics.
And voila, you have
personalized recommendations
with a heavy emphasis on
similar sounding songs.
Another use case, e-commerce,
product recommendations.
You've seen this one.
It's a very common application.
What's not very common is the
kind of improvements we drove.
We added a 105% improvement
in conversions, which
is plain, cold sales dollars.
Right?
This is dollar
value being added.
And interestingly we
also had the side effect
of increasing the
average cart size by 35%,
even though that was not a
metric we directly targeted.
And this is a thing that
happens a lot, which
is, if you have a good
personalization system,
all your metrics are
going to go up globally
even when you're focusing on
just one particular metric.
So how much work was all this?
Literally like five minutes.
You drop a beacon, just
like Google Analytics,
onto your sites, and we
collect all your data.
No need to integrate
us with the CMS.
This JavaScript already
scripts all the content
and creates a real time
snapshot of your entire content
metadata.
No need to dig
into your databases
to pull out historical
data about your users.
We collect that all in real
time from the client devices.
And within seven days,
our models are ready.
And if you want to start
showing recommendations,
you have to do the hard
work of writing one more
line of JavaScript, the one
below, which makes an API call
and starts pulling
in recommendations.
Behind all of this is a lot
of complex machine learning,
very high dimensional
regression feature.
We use some of the most
cutting edge machine
learning techniques,
and we hope to use
more as Google Cloud makes a
lot of the services available.
That will both
simplify our code base
and make the whole
system much better.
I can take more questions
later in the interest of time.
The main takeaway is all
this complex machine learning
and all this infrastructure
has one goal,
create immediate
and massive business
value for our customers.
We are the team who
made YouTube addictive.
And if you want to see an 80%
improvement in conversions
in 30 days with five
minutes of integration work,
please check out LiftIgniter.
Come find us in Startup Village.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
SAM O'KEEFE: Thank
you, Indraneel.
So if anyone else has
been looking for someone
to blame for their 4:00
AM cat video obsession,
you can talk to him after.
Next up, I'd love to
welcome Josh from Twistlock.
Josh started his career
in developer operations
before those two
words became one.
Here to talk about container
security, please welcome Josh.
[APPLAUSE]
JOSHUA THORNGREN: Hi.
Thanks everyone for coming
out today and taking some time
to hear about how
Google Cloud helps
startups like ourselves
transform the way we deliver
software to our customers.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about why Twistlock, why
I'm here standing in front of
you today, why we're a company.
With the transformation
of traditional virtualized
infrastructure into
containerized infrastructure
into microservices, what used
to be monolithic applications,
what used to be single
VM's, now split apart
across multiple artifacts.
At the same time,
the trend of DevOps
has accelerated the
way the companies
deliver software and push it
to production environments.
Whereas, there used to
be one deployment a week,
one deployment a
month sometimes,
now you have dozens of day.
That creates a very different
picture for security companies
than what the world
was like even as
recently as five years ago.
What Twistlock exists
to do is deliver
enterprise grade security
with DevOps speed,
with DevOps agility.
So talking a little
bit about our company.
We were founded in early 2015 by
a team of ex-Microsoft folks--
half of a team machine learning,
the team that built Cortana.
The other half, the team that
delivered enterprise security
to Microsoft's customers.
What they saw was
with these shifting
trends in the market,
old world security,
the notion let's just
ring fence the VM--
let's throw a firewall
up around everything--
no longer delivered the right
protection for broken apart
micro services.
So they had the idea to combine
their talents of machine
learning and security and
deliver a product that
transformed the way
security was performed
but still provided the
strength and protection
that large enterprises required.
We shipped our first
release in early 2016.
And a year later have over
40 enterprise customers
worldwide using us to
protect their production
infrastructure.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about how we do that as well
as, how our team uses
Google Cloud to deliver
those services.
And then I'll follow up
with some of the synergies
that we see when we
work with customers who
use Google Cloud themselves.
First off, speaking
about Twistlock,
we provide, what we call
end-to-end container security.
Because containers are portable
across any environment,
it's important to protect,
not only in production
but in staging, in registry,
even on developer workstations
depending on your environment.
So we provide a
number of services.
I'm going to highlight
three of them here,
vulnerability management,
runtime defense,
and compliance.
Our vulnerability management,
we scan containers
at any stage of life
cycle for malware, CVs,
misconfigurations.
Any gaps that could cause holes
to open up in your environment.
The way we do this
is we source a number
of feeds directly from vendors
and from threat providers,
threat intelligence themselves.
We don't leverage NVD or
any aggregate clearing
houses of data.
We go directly to the source.
That's packages,
operating system,
all the layers of container.
We scan for vulnerabilities
in real time.
We integrate with tools
like Jenkins or TeamCity
to alert or even
block builds based
on the number and severity
of vulnerabilities found.
Our runtime defense
feature is really
what starts to separate
Twistlock apart,
and I really like to consider
is what transforms the way we
do security from the old world.
At runtime, Twistlock
leverages the static analysis
that we've done in the
vulnerability piece.
And it combines that
with machine learning
that analyzes the
contents of a container
and uses the contents and
the behavior of container
to create and automatically
enforce a security model--
no oversight required,
no manual model creation.
That little bit of
machine learning
allows organizations to deploy
quickly and have security
for every container
in their environment
without having to write a
policy for every container
in their environment.
When a new container comes up
and it's the same container
image, that policies
automatically transferred over,
automatically applied.
This allows teams
to rapidly scale
what they do without having to
worry about how their security
organization keeps up with that.
So that's the networks, that
syscalls, that's file system,
and that's the whole
processes running
in the container itself.
It covers all four
layers of that.
That's not where it ends though.
We also offer
compliance to ensure
that your environment meets
either company or industry
standards from again,
[? build to ?] runtime.
We work closely with
NIST to do things
like translate
the HIPAA security
rule into a
containerized environment
and provide HIPAA
compliance serve customers.
We provide PCI compliance
to our customers.
And we're fully extensible
with OpenSCAP standards.
That means any
company that's looking
to provide secure compliance
across their environment
can leverage Twistlock to do so.
That's a little bit
about what we provide
as far as container security.
And we provide all of this--
our development team leverages
Google Cloud to do so.
So I'm going to talk
about that a bit.
When we first started,
it was important for us
as a cloud native company,
as a company looking
to transform the way security
was done for the new world,
we needed to find
a provider that
shared that same DNA as us, that
really understood that the way
software was being delivered is
transforming at a rapid pace.
And it was so evident,
from the start even,
that Google Cloud was the
provider in the space that
had that shared
understanding, that shared
DNA, with Twistlock.
I've got speed.
I've got flexibility.
I've got reliability up here.
And I'll talk about those.
But the thing that always
struck me coming in--
and I'm not a member of our R&D
team who made this decision.
But when we looked
at it, the thing
always struck me was
the shared terminology.
When you leverage
Google Cloud, when
you leverage Google Container
Engine, when you leverage
Google's Cloud services,
the way that the vocabulary
in the platform, in the console,
in the management tools,
is written and structured,
it's the same thing
you see in other
cloud native services.
Google talks about
containers the way
Docker talks about containers.
The way Kubernetes
talks about containers.
You don't see that
with other providers.
You see them trying to take
the language of old world
virtualization and
translate that over.
And I know that seems
like such a small thing,
but when you're talking
about shared DNA, that
was an immediate
first flag to us
that, hey, there's
some alignment
here let's keep going.
When our R&D team
evaluated, what we found
was Google Cloud Platform,
Google Container Engine, really
offered more speed than the
other options out there.
The Kubernetes native
integration, as it were,
allows our team to rapidly
deliver software and build
software on a
platform that's shared
by the majority of
our customers today.
The learns that we gain from
that process and our ability
to understand real world use
cases during the development
cycle, is extremely beneficial.
Things like one
click upgrades allow
us to instantly patch or bring
up our entire environment
without worrying about,
did we get this part?
Did we get this part?
You click.
It works.
Done.
It's not just speed though,
it's the flexibility.
The granular IAM controls,
the ease of user management,
really allows us to build
different environments
with different access for
different teams working
on different facets
of our product.
That type of granularity isn't
something you see in AWS.
That's not something
you see in Azure.
That flexibility coupled with
a wide range of OS availability
for virtual machines really
was a compelling factor for us.
The third piece, reliability.
We're a security company.
Our team needs to develop
as fast as threats come in.
If there is a zero
day that we need
to update something in
our product against,
we need to have uptime.
We can't have our VM's
down, our environment down.
Compared to Azure,
compared to AWS,
Google Cloud offered
significantly higher VM
availability and
uptime for our teams.
The other piece, we're
a security company.
We need to make sure that
the environment we develop in
is secure.
So you look at Google Cloud,
you look at the way it notifies.
When there's an
unpatched server, when
there's an incident, and there's
an open port on the firewall,
you get a notification.
That comes to you.
There's no logging into
a centralized console
to get that information.
There's no digging
through a series of menus.
That information is surfaced,
and it surfaced in real time.
For a company that prides itself
on how we deliver security,
seeing that in our cloud
provider was invaluable.
Those are some of the reasons
that our team chose Google
Cloud for our deployments.
It's helped us scale from
releasing a product a year ago,
to serving over 40
customers today.
I'd like to talk briefly
about one of those customers
and the scale and
the efficiencies
they're able to see by using
both Twistlock and Google
Cloud.
Sadly, this is one of
those things where,
I'm a security company,
everyone seems a little jittery
about being up on a
slide as oh, Twistlock
provides our security.
Understandably so.
So we'll just say a leading US
media company, joint customer
of both Google
Cloud and Twistlock.
They have over 400
Docker hosts today
and plan to scale that number to
1,000 by the end of this year.
They have over 1,000
images in their registry.
This spans 12 business
units, hundreds
of developers, all of which
make multiple deployments a day.
In the old world,
before Google Cloud,
before Twistlock, to secure
this type of environment
would require teams.
Teams for each
business unit here.
This is all done now with a
single security architect.
A single person responsible
for monitoring and enforcing
policy across this
environment and ensuring
security and compliance
as this scale continues.
This is the cloud native dream.
This is the way the world
is moving where security
is no longer a stop sign.
Security is no
longer a stoplight.
It's a traffic camera.
That's the promise of enterprise
security with DevOps agility.
That's what we do
here at Twistlock.
Feel free to come visit
us in the Startup Village
later today.
Also, feel free to get
in touch Twistlock.com.
Twistlock.com/demo.
Thank you all so much.
[APPLAUSE]
SAM O'KEEFE: Thank
you so much, Josh.
It's really amazing
when you hear
those numbers of
taking an entire team
and making just one person
able to do everything
they needed to do before.
Very impressive.
Our third company is Greta.io.
Presenting is CEO and
co-founder, Anna Ottosson.
If you can't tell
she's from Sweden,
joining us all the
way from Sweden today.
And fun fact about Greta, it may
be the only technical company
I've ever met--
feel free to correct me if
someone can combat this--
that was named after a
founder's grandmother.
Grand-grandmother, so
this has a lot of history.
Please welcome
Anna to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA OTTOSSON: Hi, everyone.
I am Anna.
And I'm the CEO and one of
the founders of Greta.io.
We're extremely happy to
be partners of Google.
And I'm very, very
glad to be here today.
So before I started
Greta, I worked
at a large European
media company,
where we, amongst
other things, streamed
Champions League, which,
at least in Europe, is
a very big thing.
But what we learned
the hard way,
really, was that
during the games,
and especially during
the most important ones,
our viewers would way too
often experience problems.
On a bad day, it could
mean a crashed service.
But even on a good
day, they would often
be met by bad image
quality or buffering,
such as in this image.
In this room, I think,
we as consumers,
can all relate to how
extremely frustrating that is.
It is exactly
situations like that,
that made us start
Greta, a completely
new way of delivering
content over the internet.
We do this by creating a new
type of infrastructure layer
on top of traditional CDNs.
The reason is that we found
that despite using CDNs,
a lot of companies
really struggle
delivering that end user
experience that we really
think their users deserve,
and especially during the most
business critical times.
Another example of
that is e-commerce.
E-commerce companies often
spend months preparing
for new campaign launches or,
for example, Black Friday,
but when their
consumers stands there
with basically money in their
hand that they want to spend,
they're often met by a crashed
site or an extremely slow one.
And the reason for
that is basically
that the internet assets built
today isn't very scalable.
And there are obviously
a million positive things
with internet, but it
has two major limitations
in the infrastructure today.
And one of those
limitations is that asset
is built on physical hardware
networks such as, CDNs,
for example.
That capacity really is limited,
which means that obviously it
can't handle infinite load.
Another big limitation
is that it's
depending on the geographical
spread of the network.
And as you can see, that
isn't very evenly distributed
throughout the world.
And we're currently
at the stage where
we're seeing consumers
in multimillion
cities such as Nairobi
and Mumbai, for example,
demanding the same type
of internet experiences
as we're used to here
in the US and Europe,
but without having the
infrastructure to support it.
So we're simply in a
situation where we have
a supply shortage of capacity.
And that will only get worse.
We are more and more connected
people, more connected devices,
but we're also consuming
heavier media types
than we've ever done before.
We see that today in the form
of HD content, for example.
But we're also seeing growing
trends such as VR and 4K.
Consumer services such
as, Twitch TV and Netflix,
for example, have also shifted
the way we consume content.
And it makes it more
likely, now than before,
that we're consuming content
at roughly the same time
of the day as for example,
our neighbors, which
further increases the
load on the already
strained infrastructure.
At Greta, we think
it's especially
those times when it's
extremely high load
and also often very business
critical such at Champions
League final or Black Friday.
That's the situations that
we find most interesting.
And the reason for that is
that by using our technology
you can actually provide the
best user experience when
it matters the most.
By adding more concurrent
users to your site or service,
you can actually deliver
higher quality faster
whilst offloading the servers.
The reason that we're
able to achieve this
is that we utilize our own
decentralized data distribution
network as one of the ways
in which we deliver content.
So basically, this means
that the more users you
add to your service or
site, the higher the density
in our network becomes.
Meaning that we can find more
optimal ways of delivering
content to your users.
This is one of our users.
It's a global audio streaming
company using our technology
today.
And in the background,
you can basically
see a screenshots of how
their concurrent users
at one point in time are
forming a Greta network.
By using our technology, they've
increased their throughput
with average of three times,
whilst offloading more than 91%
to Greta's network.
One of the things that we
find challenging, but very
interesting with
building relatively
complex infrastructure
technology,
is packaging that
technology in a way
that makes it truly accessible
to developers and companies.
That's why we are very proud
that most of the sites using
our technology deploy our
script without any hands on help
from us.
And often, they have
it live in production
in less than 10 minutes,
which we find pretty amazing.
By adding our script,
you get access
to our analytics platform,
where we basically
look at all your content
delivery solutions today
and how they affect your
performance and user
experience.
We then take all
that data and feed it
into our intelligent
routing algorithms
and can thereby determine
what route will actually
give the end user the
best possible experience.
Our product today consists,
amongst other things,
of CDN evaluation, peer-to-peer
delivery, Smart Cache
solutions, as well as
performance analytics
and reports.
And it feels like I've said the
word performance minimum 100
times the last minutes.
And I'm sure you are fed up
with it day three of GCP,
but it truly is our
obsession at Greta.
And it's also that
obsession that's
made it very natural for us
to work with GCP from day one.
And I am actually
not saying this
because they've paid my
ticket and everything,
I truly mean it.
And I thought some of you
might find it interesting
how we utilize GCP.
So another big reason why we
worked closely with Google
already from the
beginning is that we're
utilizing the technology WebRTC
to do a lot of what we do.
And for those of you
not familiar with it,
it's a web standard
where Google have been
one of the main initiators.
Furthermore, at GCP, it's
obviously important for us
to get access to the network.
And that is why we use
their load balancing.
We use Google Container
Engine to host our services,
and we use BigQuery and
CloudSQL to store data.
We're obviously
continuously looking
at how we can improve
what we do and how we
can do so with the help of GCP.
Some of the things that we're
really excited about adding
is the things to the right here.
So for our persistent
data, we're
currently adding
Cloud Spanner, which
it has been a lot of talk
about here at GCP Next.
So basically, the
reason we use Spanner
is to be able to do data
replication with low latency.
But the thing that we're truly
excited about and waiting for
is the global version
of Spanner, which will
be released later this year.
In order to handle
our network data
we are adding Cloud Pub/Sub
together with Dataflow.
And this allows us to enrich
and analyze our network data.
Furthermore, we
are experimenting
with Google's Machine
Learning Platform
as part of our offering
[? is ?] prediction
and anomaly detection.
But what I've told
you here today
is really only the beginning.
We are extremely excited to
keep working with Google,
and we're very, very excited
about continuing our journey
towards changing the
way the internet works.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
SAM O'KEEFE: Thank you, Anna.
Before I bring up
our last presenter,
I want to remind everyone that
following this presentation
we are going to be
taking questions.
So there's a microphone
set up in the middle here.
Don't be shy.
And they can be directed at
any of our four presenters,
so start thinking
of those questions.
But now I'd love to welcome
to the stage Matthew,
from Incorta.
Matthew describes himself
as equal part engineer
and equal part
enterprise sales, Having
spent 15 years at Oracle.
Today he's here to talk about
how to make analytics truly
real time.
Please welcome Matthew.
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW HALLIDAY: So we
think that the earth is flat.
We used to think that
flight is impossible.
We used to think that 640K was
more memory than any computer
system would probably ever need.
We used to think
that really there
was only one enterprise cloud.
Until last year, we used to
think that the Cubs would never
win the World Series.
But it takes people like the
Wright brothers and Pythagoras
to really come and challenge
these things that are really
our core beliefs that are
held, perceived truths,
that everyone is operating
under the pretense
that these are true.
And so it's into that
world that Incorta steps.
And for the last 25 years,
we've seen a lot of complexity
in trying to get to performance.
So Incorta has a fundamental
belief that we can change that.
I'm going to talk about
that same mentality,
that same approach, that
the Wright brothers had.
And you've got to remember
that they were at a time
when everyone was
saying that it's
impossible to fly unless you
had a gas that was lighter
than air.
That was the common held belief.
And so there is a
common held belief
that's been around
for 25, 30 years,
that I want to share with
you today and then talk
a little bit about how
Incorta shatters that belief.
So at the beating heart
of every enterprise,
you will find an ERP system.
You'll find something that's
registering every business
activity, every sale, every
order, every supply chain
event, any collections, revenue.
They're all going to flow
through a data model that
looks something like this.
This data model is what we
refer to as a normalized model.
It's lots of tables with
lots of relationships.
So you have an
online transaction
based processing system.
This is actually
a schema, that's
a real world schema, that's
used significantly through most
of the Fortune 1000 companies
and this is actually
just one query.
This is the content, these
are the relationships
in the joins that are needed
to give you something.
Now, this model
works pretty well
when you're looking at
something like one transaction.
This model falls apart
the moment you say,
I want to look at my
data across everything,
and I want to slice
and dice it any way I
want based upon the
information that I have.
And so for the last 25 years,
we've seen a lot of innovation.
But it's all been
down the wrong path
because they believed the joins
and relationships between data
could never be fast.
Joins and sorts are what
kill a database performance.
So we started with extract
transform and load,
ETL processes.
People started to automate them.
Have automated testing for them.
All of this innovation
was poured into ETL.
People looked at star
schemas, or cube structures,
or summarized data, to be able
to put the data into a shape
that maybe the relational
database can minimize the joins
and give you that data
in a timely fashion.
And then there was
other companies
that jumped up
and said, you know
what, we're going to make really
hefty, big pieces of hardware.
We're going to charge
a million dollars
plus for this piece of hardware
that is an appliance that
will sit in your data center
and promises to give you
unparalleled performance.
But what happened?
We had frustrated
business users and we
had a super busy IT department.
And so people would spend
months, if not years,
iterating on star
schemas, trying
to find out what my
business requirements?
What do my business
users want to see?
And then I'll spend the next
year and a half building it.
They'll take a look at it,
and then they would say, oh,
that's interesting.
What about this?
Well, you didn't ask me that.
Let me go back and
I'll come back.
And so they'll be looking
at data that is static.
Very, very much set
in stone in terms
of how they want to look at it,
but also it pretty much always
be yesterday's data.
These ETL processes can take 12
to 13 hours, nightly refreshes,
and people are just,
that's what we do.
That's what we've been doing?
That's what we're expecting.
And you would think after
doing all this complex work
that it would be fast.
Right?
Well, it was certainly faster
than a relational database
with joins, but
it was still slow,
some jobs taking five minutes
even up to 90 minutes.
Run your job, go for lunch,
come back hoping that it's done.
And so Incorta steps
into that and said,
if we can do something
very special,
we can change the
fundamental approach
and reverse that decision
from 25 years ago,
and say, there is a better way.
Incorta's Direct Data
Mapping is exactly that.
You can think of it as a
technology that enables
joins to perform.
It knows exactly how
every piece of data
within a relational model
relates to each other.
No need for star schemas.
You can set this up
in hours and days.
You can refresh in minutes.
We have customers
here in the Bay Area
that are upgrading
every five minutes.
They're getting the
latest and greatest data
flowing into their system.
And with all of that
you say, OK, great.
It's faster.
Looks easy.
It's quicker.
Time to value, but
surely it's slower.
Well, it's not the
same speed for sure.
We're talking orders
of magnitude--
50, 100 times faster than some
of these other approaches.
So going back to
this schema again--
I want to show you something.
This is a schema we
showed up at the front.
I want to show you a little
bit about how does this work?
So that schema has over
a billion records in it.
I'm going to show you
now 11 table joins.
And we're going to see the
response in 0.8 seconds.
So what does that look like?
So does anyone want to see it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah!
MATTHEW HALLIDAY: Sorry.
MATTHEW HALLIDAY: OK cool.
So let's see this in action.
So here you can see a Tableau
dashboard running on top
of Incorta's Data Platform.
And every click is
resulting in all
of these things being redone.
If you've used
Tableau in your past,
you probably go, this
doesn't look like the Tableau
I'm familiar with.
I normally expect
the spinning wheel.
Did you edit it out?
What happened?
No, this is real.
If you don't believe me, stop
by the booth in the Startup
Village and we'll
show you it in action.
But this kind of response
with this complexity,
without the need to
transform your data,
has never been done before.
And so next question
is, why Google Cloud?
Well, there's a few things here.
One of the things
that we notice when
we're speaking with our
customers is elastic scaling.
We definitely wanted to have
a system and a platform that
enabled us to grow with the
demands of our customers.
We have customers
here in San Francisco
like [? hypergrowth ?]
startups that
are kind of like
Spotify for clothes
that are providing analytics to
their users using this system.
Of course at different
parts of the year,
they are going to have
different demands.
And to be able to spin up
and grow your system in less
than 10 minutes is something
that was really, really unique.
Also, price performance.
A lot of talk about performance.
But really it's going to come
down to a predictable cost.
Can I know exactly what this
is going to cost me next month
or am I going to be
guessing what my budget?
How do I budget for this?
How do I plan?
And that's where Incorta felt
that Google Cloud was very,
very straightforward but
also a very good price
point for performance.
And the third one, no shock
here at Google right, but this
would be developer friendly.
Probably everyone
here might well
be from a developer background
and it doesn't stop here.
It's very unlikely
that you would
get invited to even speak
into the direction of a cloud
company as a startup.
And we have found that to be
very true with our relationship
with Google Cloud.
And so I want to talk about
one of those things that
has come out of this
relationship with Google Cloud
that we think is super exciting.
So here, I'm glad
to announce that we
have a special way
for enterprises
to get to the Cloud.
Now, we have a lot
of enterprises that
historically have data centers.
If you've been around for
probably more than 10 years,
you probably have a data center.
And you probably know, I
want to get to the cloud,
but how do I get there?
Am I going to take
everything down and move,
or do I want to do it in pieces?
Or how can I augment what I have
with some additional resources
from the Cloud?
And so Incorta
provides the ability
to have a single dashboard and
have different components that
look to the user seamless.
They're just getting
served content.
Where that content
is coming from
could be Incorta
running on Google Cloud
or it could be Incorta running
on your own data centers.
So content that maybe you're
not prepared to yet put
in the Cloud, you can
keep it on your premises
locally in your data center.
But data maybe that
you want to use
for other teams or
other people to be
able to leverage
the power of Incorta
on that platform to be able
to do that with Google Cloud.
And to give you
that extensibility
to grow and to shrink as
needed when demands are met.
So with that, I'd like to
invite you to come speak to us.
We will be at the Startup
Village for a few more hours.
And if you're
unable to make that,
definitely start by Incorta.com.
We'd love to show you a demo
and to talk more about that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]